"I don't think this will work, nor am I totally sure why I'm doing this."
...should be the opening for every video I've ever made on the internet ever.
Yes, all of my hair extensions fell out because I went swimming over the weekend,
and yes, I did run forehead-first into a tree,
the only tree in the backyard,
and yes, I was sober.
Don't worry, you're better than me. That's why I'm fun to watch.
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know now you know, your life is different now!
The 4th of July just happened. The summer is here.
It's barbecue central, I assume, unless you don't like that,
and two of the most major summer barbecue foods are hot dogs and hamburgers.
But, because I have free time, I thought,
"what if you made hamburgers out of hotdogs?"
Sports.
Hot Burgers, ham dogs.
Ham dogs isn't bad. Ham dogs is also the...
you know, probably the only sporting team I would root for.
Ham dogs!
So that's what we're going to do today!
I don't have a grill, but I have an indoor grill.
I also got some ground chicken breasts to make actual chicken hamburgers,
but I was gonna stuff some of them with these wieners.
The entire aesthetic of my food and cooking has just been,
"How can I put a weiner in that?"
Deal with it.
Okay. Let's just do this!
So the first thing we're going to do is grind up our wieners.
Wife me up somebody!
I'm going to use this.
We're gonna grind on our weens and then we're going to see if they can stick together.
Just gonna rough chop some weens and add them to our...
chopping... thing.
WIFE. ME. UP.
ASMR.
Did you hear that?
Not only was that two weens slapping together, it was also sound of this video getting flagged.
Okay, rough chop.
[sexy music playing]
That's sexual.
Something's very cathartic about this.
Little known fact, Lorena Bobbitt was an amazing chef. Here we go!
[food processor making noise]
Whoa, this is working.
Wow! It's working [laughs]. Whoa!
The odor is specific. Look at that. Look!
Again, I don't know why anyone would need to try and do this in their lives. Hot dogs are pretty good as is.
But, if you like staving off your own boredom, maybe try this.
Put our wieners in the bowl. This did grind this very well.
I was worried that it wouldn't be moist enough to bind together,
but whatever meat's in a hot dog... moist!
So now I'm going to add some breadcrumbs and an egg because that's sometimes what goes in hamburgers.
Watch. I can crack it with one hand.
That...is actually a good job.
Oh no. Am I turning a corner becoming capable?
[shudder sound]
Wow! This is working well...and I feel uncomfortable with that.
So the breadcrumbs. Now we mix that up because... [shrug]
Ooh! Salt and pepper? I guess because we're doing well!
Now let's get our grill pan out and start heating that up.
Now let's form these wieners into patties.
Oh! Touching it does not feel nice.
That's what you want every girl to say about your ween.
Look at that! Disgusting!
And almost identically my skin color, which just adds to how disgusting this is.
Why are we doing this?
Please subscribe.
So out of those four hot dogs we got three patties.
Let's put some oil on the grill.
Let's put our wiener patties on the grill.
Wait, ho no no. I'll bring you guys over. You can see it better.
Yeah. Hey guys. 'Sup? Welcome to this part of the kitchen.
[meat sizzling on grill ] Whoa!
That sounds like cooking is happening.
The good thing about hot dogs is because it's not real meat,
I think it doesn't matter if it cooks completely through.
Don't quote me on that.
Can you eat hot dogs raw? Can you raw dog...a hot dog?
Now we cook them for an indefinite and undetermined amount of time.
Eww! Don't look at how dirty everything is over there. Stop judging me.
Oh, man.
I love nature.
Like what a young girl tries to do to her closeted boyfriend, let's flip 'em.
Whoa! That looks burnt. That's bullsh*t.
So we burned them big time.
But they look more like...
hamburgers now.
Put you back in your other spot. I don't want you to get this close to the failures that are currently happening.
Ok! I don't know if they're cooked in the middle,
but, that's the fun gamble in cooking:
you wonder if you're going to make yourself sick.
They smell...specific.
Also, I got some cheese to try one with cheese on it.
I have a lactose sensitivity, so I got nut cheese.
Why does everything sound like I'm putting a scrotum in my mouth?
I'll do two with cheese.
Whoa...look at that.
Now it has cheese on it. And I got ketchup and mustard.
Let's do that because why not.
Whoa! I overshot. Wow. That's beautiful.
I know some of you don't like mixing things, but deal with it.
Top our hot burgers. Ham dogs.
Whoa! Whoa. Look how convincing these look!
Look at that!
They look like real hamburgers... kind of.
There you go! We got our ham dogs.
Again, don't know why this would even be something interesting for you to try at home.
But if you do, please tweet photos at me or tag me on Instagram.
I'm @gracehelbig across all social media platforms.
I feel like I've underwhelmed myself. Let's try one.
Cheers!
I don't know if it's raw in the middle, but I'm swallowing it.
The echoes of "that's what she says" ring proudly through the land.
Not bad you guys! Pretty okay.
I feel so mediocre about everything that's happening right now, wow okay.
I should leave before something spectacular or miserable happens.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
If you like this video give it a thumbs up and click subscribe
because I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
Sometimes. Unless it's a holiday.
And umm, unless it's just...
I don't know.
"I can't get my Grey Poupon open!"
Please don't leave. Please stay. [laughs]